the Joe Rogan experience maybe you got
eaten by a bear that's a way to go boy
if you gotta be eaten by any animal what
would it be no the bigger the better
shark over quick
uh no not shark I don't like that
because I don't like my head being here
in the evils under here and it's gonna
take a bite out of me first to see if
I'm edible oh and you just sitting there
you know missing a chunkier leg going
please don't let me taste good please
don't let me tell you let him just
[ __ ] leave it's interesting sharks
used to be if you caught a shark people
were happening
you got that [ __ ] thing out of the
water good like when fishermen would
bring in a shark people would get
excited yeah now you're a monster
well there's this thing that I follow
about sharks on Instagram and like it's
[ __ ] this person found a tiger shark
18-footer or some [ __ ] right and he she
went down that she somehow gained this
things confident and had like a fish
some fishing line and like took it out
okay if this this can't be real and then
somehow she ran into the thing again in
the ocean and she was petting it like a
[ __ ] lap dog trying to suggest that
this thing knew her knew her and was
happy and respect it mean the way they
cut it together and of course the music
always takes you emotionally where they
want you to go but I was just watching
that whole thing going like it's good
that you did that but I don't think
you're at the I can now this tiger shark
is talked to all the other tiger shots
not on out Bill's cool do you remember
Beastmaster remember that TV show no
there was a dude who's like a jack dude
and like big bracelets on and he was
[ __ ] commune with the animals and
they would like land on his shoulder and
[ __ ] like eagles would land on his arm
and all the animals would listen to him
it's not a really stupid show because
it's he there's no there's nothing
humble about that name Beastmaster
Beastmaster see they're allowing you to
live and you're acting yeah you gotta
have the Tarzan hair who was the guy in
peace
master who was it a TV show now it was a
show I think it was a TV show was a TV
show that guy like had this special
relationship with the [ __ ] with the
animals they all listen to him oh yeah I
didn't know he had a sword too so it was
this big dick to judge him by how long
that [ __ ] name flat face huh hang it
down below his knees if you don't have a
big dick the line it's not gonna listen
you look that Eagles landed on his arm
yeah he this was like the Conan the
Barbarian days like after Conan the
movie was a giant hit there was a lot of
dudes with their shirts off holding
swords holding swords it was a thing
tell him lions where to go yeah it was
I'll tell you one thing that I would
never do in acting is I will never ever
catch I probably shouldn't say this but
like working with monkeys aside from you
know it's gonna be a bad movie no
[ __ ] way
I worked with the writer who got
attacked by a monkey when he was a kid
and it was just one of those
organ-grinder ones in show business man
it's gotta thanks thanks for the
organ-grinder music and their fat monk
and he was talking about like his
clarity and understanding of monkeys
just by getting attacked by one he goes
nah he goes I won't do it he go she do
like you're good for about 18 20 minutes
and then the monkey just starts [ __ ]
acting crazy and then eventually it just
gets like you know I've always said that
you are in a circle like a circus like a
bear doesn't want to ride a bicycle so
what did they do to that [ __ ] thing
to make it give in yeah and it's a bear
so eventually it's gonna become a bear
again you know and it's something's good
like all like thought those circus all
that [ __ ] it's just that it's inevitable
like what you're doing yeah circus is a
dark is that what they do to elephants
and monkeys and
Paris there's a great video it's not a
good well it's horrible do you have any
happy videos of animals just existing I
don't save those I know your dumb system
chilling out does a video of a chimp
riding a bike and a girl in a bear
riding a bike and the chimp tripped up
the bear somehow and they crashed and
the bear grabs a hold of chimp just rips
it apart from everybody with that [ __ ]
yeah here it is so the Bears riding and
the chimps riding and they collide and
when they collide the bear is [ __ ]
furious at the chimp and just starts
[ __ ] ragheads like road rage right
boom goes down and he tries to help him
back get back on the bike is this it
this is the one oh he's got the chimp
right there oh yeah it's too late I
thought they'd have a muzzle on the
[ __ ] thing well not this time they
trusted him so he just [ __ ] up that
chimp and they can't get it away from
him that's not even a big bear it's a
small bear no dude that's [ __ ] huge
would you want to fight that guy in a
bar no guy that stocky that hairy coming
at you that's Georgie animal Steele it's
just such a stupid [ __ ] form of
entertainment you know let's get animals
to do [ __ ] that they don't normally do
people are freaking out well I like it
took them that long to stand up to
realize that's not part of the show
something about music you can just take
you emotionally where you want them
[Applause]